this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
good evening a man is shot and killed at
a central valley laundromat and police
are still looking for the suspect this
all unfolding just after eight o'clock
tonight not too far from maryland
parkway and desert inn orco man live
near that intersection with more on what
is a developing situation orco
well brian and denise there are a lot of
metro police cars out here in front of
this 24 hour laundromat where the
steadily shooting happened you can also
see the crime scene tape blocking off
the area now we just got an update from
metro police just minutes ago and here's
what we know police say multiple people
called 9-1-1 to report shots fired near
the laundromat when officers got here
they found a man who was shot they took
him to the hospital where he later died
police told us that there were a group
of males between the ages of 18 and 25
two of them got into a fight exchanged
gunfire and then one of those males
again between the age of 18 and 25 that
man was shot taken in the hospital and
died and this happened right across the
boulevard mall and we spoke to a man who
was shopping there at the time of the
shooting
and we heard about six to seven shots um
the first ones well we just looked
around real quick we saw a bunch of
people jumping inside the laundromat
sadly this is a normal thing now here
down in maryland parkway in this area
especially lately it seems to be more
and more
metro police tell us the person
responsible for the shooting left the
area and officers are trying to find
them now several other people also left
the scene here so if you know anything
about what happened you're asked to call
either police or crime stoppers where
you can remain anonymous reporting live
in las vegas tonight orco mana live
local now